here's Jane Fonda talking about killing
people we have experienced many decades
now of having agency over our body of
being able to determine when and how
many children to have we know what that
what that feels like we know what that's
done for our lives we're not going back
I don't care what the laws are we're not
going to die and protesting what else do
you suggest
well it doesn't happen overnight it's
not a miraculous what did you say murder
[Laughter]
the point is if this was flipped in
Reverse if the view ever had a pro-life
activist on and they were like well what
would you like to do with people who
provide abortion abortions and they were
like kill them murder that would be good
that person would never be on television
again they're all of their gigs would be
canceled they would be banned gone
canceled